true crime has uh there's something
about true crime it's like blowing up in
the last couple years the last like two
years i want to say no it's
like the last five or ten years it's
really been getting big
it is [ __ ] like true crime has become
one of the most popular genres right now
not only for podcasts but for shows like
netflix
yeah now they're kind of getting
converted into
uh like the net like the netflix series
they're like converting
like dirty john all of those yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] insane even my like my
wife all she watches is [ __ ] [ __ ]
about people getting raped and murdered
women
love like they like the truth they like
the really that's all my mom watches
it's like seventy percent she's either
watching the news or she's watching like
the id channel
yeah i can't watch people getting
murdered yeah it's too fake some of the
stuff on tv though is just their true
stories they're true they're true
stories but the way they dramatically
fantasize them and drama
like like there's a ufo thing on history
channel about uh skinwalk skinwalker
ranch and it's just
the way it's produced and the way they
skin walker ranch
there's a ranch in utah that has all
kinds of paranormal
phenomena all kind of paranormal
phenomena that happens with like crazy
magnets and [ __ ] up iphones water
it's water
it's weird drinking water out of it it
is i mean i don't drink beer anyway but
even when i look at it i
hold it up should i hold it up it's
going to smile do a promo for liquid
death response of the podcast
who is it it's liquid death it's a water
company what do you think about their
water
i it tastes good this tastes like death
better than the tap
no um their slogan is murder your thirst
murder your thirst look at that they
sent me a [ __ ] giant
stack of water and sparkling water nice
it's good it is good
i don't know what the sparkling water is
like but this is good yeah it's good
it's great it's great it's uh drinking
water from the alps
yeah it's like drinking water melon
water a beer can
it's been washed out really good
anyways the the [ __ ] that's on tv shows
is just it's so
over produced and dramatist and
dramatized dramatized that's the word i
was looking for
and it just makes me just like whenever
something's overproduced and dramatized
like that it just makes me
makes me skeptical of it yeah it's like
watching american greed
yeah where matthew conman walked into
the office
yeah another single mother
yeah oh [ __ ]
um oh yeah true crime and then women
women are like
are like it gets better it gets better i
got called
another thing i got called from a guy
who did every year seeing um
oh god it's called uh hold on it's on a
e it's called uh
um 60 days in uh
i've seen it on the scrolling through
but i've never watched it
okay so i've watched a couple episodes
because this guy contacted me like a
week or so ago like
never check instagram people contact me
on instagram like i check it maybe once
or twice a month
and they'll be like 30. and so as i'm
going through like you know accept and
you know oh cool thanks
you know and giving them you know little
responses this one guy says hey
if he hadn't put a e in the name of the
show he would have gotten nothing
yeah like if it was just like hey bro
watch your stuff you're awesome
you know give me a call but instead he
was like i'm so and so from you know
i'm tony his name is tony from a e he
has a bunch of guys have reached out a
bunch of my fans have reached out to me
and said i need to interview you i need
to contact
you i've watched your stuff on on on
youtube
you know great stuff really want to talk
to you about being interviewed and talk
to you about a
e in bubble i was like it's like a week
or so i was like oh god
so i responded i talked to him the other
day he wants to interview me for some
show for a
e talking about possibly trying to do
some kind of accomplishment for the 60
days in show
no for something totally different but
they're they're like hooked in with him
now
you know he was a big he was basically
the star of that show okay
and so there he's now doing kind of like
a spin-off show
and so same thing it's it's so there's
lots of stuff that constantly happening
is just trying not to get in
hooked into that trap where you end up
signing a bunch of stuff
and then nothing happens get your hopes
up on it right but imagine if you if you
didn't have a podcast if you didn't have
any sort of other thing if you didn't
have anything else going on you'd be
like oh yeah they'd want to they want to
sign you up exclusively for them and you
would have nothing else you know what i
mean
now you have leverage when you start
putting out your own [ __ ] that you own
independently you have leverage against
those people and they know that right
what you know
and it's funny too because guys always
tell me like i always get guys like
what does danny pay you for that what is
that like well nothing bro you
don't
do understand so then you have to break
it down you understand
what's happened like like concrete me
put me
on like i was already out and doing
stuff but
like you know i was already in a couple
magazines and i was trying to but you
were still in the halfway house when you
came on this show the first time no no i
just got out i wouldn't do it in the
halfway house i was
so scared right you wouldn't do it you
were not allowed to you did super scared
um and he was even like come well first
of all i couldn't i can't disappear for
four hours like there's no way to go
across listen you're so scared in the
halfway house like they're they're
knocking people off yeah they're ready
to sit
right back in jail so you know he's like
yeah come over and this
i'm like i'll hold it and then so i got
out and then he called me i've been out
like a month or a few weeks or something
you're like bro
i answered your questions yeah because
i'd asked you about
oh yeah podcast yeah answered your
question said you were going to come on
you're not in the thing
i had a i had somebody fought somebody
um didn't show up yeah someone
rescheduled last minute
i need i i got nothing like in the can i
need to do something
i need to come out i was like all right
so i came out
but you know i explained that i said
look danny put me on a course
because of the podcast put me on a
course and got me exposure that i never
would have gotten
had i said oh well you could give me 500
bucks you know what i'm saying or you go
to then he'd have been like
screw you i'll go get i'll go just have
a conversation with anybody for
you know forget it i'm not gonna do it
okay so
then what where would i be i'd be
pushing i'd be pushing books on my own
it has been said that i i have had
people tell me that i am the joe rogan
of florida
oh god who the [ __ ] gasped you up like
no it's been said i've been it's been
said it could be a fact i'm just saying
it could be a fact
matt you didn't fuel that comment to his
head did you no
i've had a guest come on here and say it
and i've had i've seen at least one
comment that said that
so it could i could it could be true who
knows anyways you've done great for
yourself you you've really taken off you
really uh
you really i'm not making a bunch of
money but a lot of things are happening
like something's got hit
there's so much stuff up in the air
right now like it's so much being thrown
into the wall something's got to stick
for sure yeah but it's not about one
thing sticking
it's about staying consistent and that's
what you're doing right now i'm staying
i'm staying on and i'm putting stuff i'm
putting up and and and the energy it's a
snowball effect right it's a snowball
effect
the first podcast was the spark that lit
the flame right now it just keeps
growing and growing and it's the inner
it it's all the it's and i look i i like
doing the podcasts
like i like look like um juan juan i'm
gonna interview this chick that it's
great juan's great too because he works
who you talking about juan sanchez okay
he's the ex-con that you just uh
interviewed the guy from venezuela like
got kidnapped in venezuela
39 million dollars he's got a great
story
um but just so happens he knows somebody
knows a chick that was a high-end madam
who was bringing girls in i'm gonna say
from like
brazil or something i don't know that it
was some south american country i don't
know which one
but she was bringing girl so they can
come in like you can come in for like 90
days
to the united states yeah come hang out
whatever on vacation so
they would come in for 90 days so this
girl's get this woman's getting phone
calls
from women in let's say brazil she's
spanish too
and um they're calling her and saying
look
i can come to the united states for 90
days i need to make some money
and she's setting it like supermodel hot
looking
and they're coming in and they're
working as high-end escorts
she's so she's i don't want to say
pimping him out she likes it
she is okay yeah i mean not the best
possible she's a pimp
she's pimping out so she's being a madam
to these women and they're they're
coming and they're
they're going back like a jizz lane you
could jizz lane maxwell
um on a different level yes that was
epstein's girl
oh was it oh no no no no who is pro
procuring
yeah but these are adult women these are
oh they're not they're not kids oh no
no no it's not like sex trafficking well
it is sex trafficking
anyway look so this chick comes in so
these girls are coming in for 90 days
and then they're going back to like
venezuela or colombia or brazil
with 50 grand 50 grand is going back
there's like
going back there with like 400 000 right
it's a huge amount of money
you can buy a condo and still have years
worth of income left
so they're going back there with time
and so then those girls go back there
they tell this person this girl next to
those next you know she's just running
them left and right and he sent me her
indictment i read her her indictment i
read her
uh stipulation of facts i'm like counts
with four hundred thousand accounts with
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
this girl got paid eighty thousand this
girl got sixty 000 this girl got
i mean these chicks are coming in and
they're just lining them up i was like
this chick's probably got a pretty good
story
this is a pretty interesting story she
did this for years
so she's coming in i'm gonna do her on
my podcast on
on wednesday next wednesday um
juan's gonna come back juan's gonna do
do uh concrete yeah she'll be better
than mine because
and you're gonna be here too oh yeah i
mean i'll be if you whatever you guys
decide
yeah he's you'll be able to do a better
podcast like i just sat there and
thought he was just gonna
tell his story like i didn't interview
him really does that make sense
because i'd heard him say his story so
many times i thought he was gonna just
roll it on out yeah but he's like i
haven't told anybody that story in
like like when did he tell you that
story in prison in prison seven or eight
years right
okay so he went to keep in mind he left
he went to
he went to an ice facility he went to so
he had a whole thing after we met so
he hasn't been telling that story so he
was like yeah yeah yeah so here's what i
did so he he threw out some stuff and i
was like whoa whoa i kept having to go
whoa whoa
what about this and he was like oh yeah
yeah i forgot about
yeah so what happened then he tell that
story i go what about
how the story about how you got the
money to pay for your attorney
that is a good story yeah that's good
let me tell you that and it's like
it wasn't as good you know yeah
like i felt like it wasn't good colby my
my video editor he was like bro that was
amazing was a great story it was great
it was like
but i had an anticipation of what it was
in my mind
right yeah it was different man you know
it would be great for the prison
industrial complex as if the people who
own the prisons
they set up in the prison cells they set
up podcasts
so everyone in prison could have their
own podcast their own youtube show
and the prisons could make so much
[ __ ] money
by pimping out these prisoners to have a
true crime podcast
that's that's not imagine it imagine how
much money they could have selling
[ __ ] arrest them all fill those
prisons up now we can have more podcasts
make more
make more podcast money we can have
deals with spotify jesus
the president that escalated quickly if
i was going to say there are first of
all they're already
filled up yeah they're already going to
be fulfilled you really just need to
bring in them
so okay prison owners if you want to
make more money
do deals with spotify fill the prison
cells with microphones and set up
podcasts with the prisoners that way
they can have their podcasts
in prison and the prisons can do spotify
deals directly
and it'll be [ __ ] hands over fist
millions
never happened never happened in federal
system they won't let sure will they
won't let a camera in
they won't let you come in and video an
inmate in prison
not since not since was it diane sawyer
did it or was it barbara walters did she
did one for 60 minutes and it was called
uh
it was called um a club fed where they
actually went into a prison a camp
and showed the facility and how nice the
facility was
and people went nuts like you know
because they're
they're showing guys playing tennis
they're showing guys doing fishing
they're doing this they're doing that
and they're like
oh and she's like she's she's going oh
what'd you have for dinner he's like ah
we had this and
you know he's like oh we had like he's
saying all these things that sound good
and so they immediately after that whole
thing they went in and they said
the federal the uh bureau of prison said
we're never letting another camera in
because they made us look like fools
and we're taking away this and this they
started they literally are paving over
all the stuff they're tearing up
everything they just took
everything away yeah but who cares
anymore who cares anymore everybody
knows
everybody talks about it everybody knows
all the [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] that goes on
in prisons but they were playing they
were portraying that
it was club fed they were saying it was
like club it was too nice
right so they went in but who cares well
it's too late
you care now because it's not now right
now it's a statement so that's
practically the statement exactly so let
the cameras in now
like give them podcasts i i and i think
you should take that on but having dealt
with the
bureaucracy of federal the federal
prison system i can tell you it's
never going to happen i think it's time
for the federal prison system to give in
to the interesting so too and look as
as feeble as biden is you could probably
fool them into signing something
you know but yeah true crime is
profitable